so hello I'm John gene accomplice
professor in the Economics Department
and the chair of Hellenic studies
welcome all of you to the 14th annual
Stavros Niarchos foundation lecture
these lectures I think a lot of you've
been here before
bringing to the Yale campus
distinguished scholars and the
humanities and social sciences public
figures and artists of international
reputation as you know the series is
funded by the Niarchos Foundation which
funds in fact the whole program program
started in 2001 with a pilot program
then in 2007 after we some of our great
teachers showed their capacities the
narcos foundation funded it as a
permanent program it established a
center here the Arco Center and
continues to fund it on an ongoing basis
out of the endowment so this is
something that's permanent now the
program isn't the only thing the
Niarchos foundation does here it funds
all sorts of other things in the School
of Art and the Peabody Museum the Center
for globalization that we're the first I
believe that you funded at Yale
hopefully still the most important that
you've released the dearest that you
fund at Yale so I'd like to welcome from
the Niarchos foundation was Taylor
Glazebrook who I think is gonna say a
few words and mr. Chris Davey who
represent the foundation and we express
our gratitude as always for your own
generous and unwavering support now you
can tell already from my name that I'm
completely objective when I say that the
theme of us evening Greek exceptionalism
is an important one what makes me even
more objective when I say that is I
sacrificed my second son to the subject
Philip Alexander whose name of course
has nothing to do with Greek
exceptionalism is now studying of all
things ancient Greece at Harvard and
politics at Harvard University the home
Institute
of our distinguished speaker professor
Hertz felt amazingly my son has taught
me something about the most exceptional
aspects of Greece coming this Tuesday
for instance election day we can only
hope that the fundamental principles of
democracy which ancient Greece Greece
gifted us will be renewed on behalf of a
citizenry even more diverse than the
citizens re-grease imagined but I'm
anticipating it's still Thursday and
what we have to look forward to right
now is the exceptional brilliance of
Michel Hertzfeld but before we give him
a chance to speak I think we have a few
words from the New York ohs foundation
Taylor welcome thank you very much it's
a pleasure to be here this evening and
on behalf of the entire Foundation staff
thank you all for being here the Stavros
Niarchos foundation has been in
existence for 22 years and we're very
proud that for the vast majority of that
time we've had a meaningful and
impactful relationship with Yale
University the SNF has a broad mandate
and has thus far committed more than 2.6
billion dollars through more than 4,000
grants to nonprofit organizations in 124
countries in the areas of arts and
culture education health and sports and
Social Welfare this broad scope of our
mandate is reflected in the breadth of
our relationship with Yale with SNF
support to Yale programs in art medicine
and of course International Studies with
the Center for Hellenic studies in each
case the SNF seeks to support the
critical practice of knowledge creation
and perhaps most importantly the
practice of knowledge sharing that takes
place at events like this one we're
about to hear from professor Herzfeld
about the perils of exceptionalism but
through these events we see the benefits
of an exceptional commitment to
scholarship the other half of the talks
title Greece no larger universe
perfectly encapsulates a final important
element of the of SF's mission given to
us by our founder the late Stavros
Niarchos at least 50% of our grant
two Greek related causes a threshold
that we surpass it's exciting to see
that focus on Hellenic culture
articulated in a setting like this and
we look forward to hearing from you
professor herzfeld thank you before I
start reading my prepare the words well
then why don't I speak off the cuff for
a second
literally thank you Michael for giving
me the opportunity to wear my tie that I
do once a year and of course the cliche
is that it's a pleasure to present the
distinguished speaker and this year it's
an even bigger pleasure for me because I
have known Michael Hertzfeld for nearly
30 years now I was a student the first
semester you were at Harvard did one of
your introductory classes and it's a
real pleasure to present him because I
honestly and very sincerely respect the
man and the scholar have admired him for
what he has given to the field and I'm
still in awe at his never-ending
productivity he's a model that is
difficult to actually imitate but I'll
try and praise his laurels today
formally and informally because I do
know his scholarship and I know the
effect that he has had but I also over
the years have gotten to know the person
that I think is even as remarkable as
his work so Michael Herzfeld is the
Ernest monitor professor of the social
sciences and director of the Thai
Studies Program at the Asia Center at
Harvard University for nearly four
decades he has been the leading
anthropologist of Greece and a
pioneering figure in the second wave of
Greek anthropology which dominated the
field of modern Greek studies in the
1990s we used to say that the 80s was
the decade of literature the 90s belongs
to the anthropologists and for the rest
I'll leave it for the historians yes he
broke into the field in 1982
with the book called hours once more
folklore ideology in the making of
modern Greece which remains to this day
the definitive study of Greek folk do
you appear in many of my classes at
least partly with access from that book
he continued on with another five books
on topics that relate to Greece I will
not list all of his bibliography because
we don't have forever and I'll mention a
few that have been quite a formative in
shaping the field the poetics of manhood
contests an identity in a Cretan
mountain village anthropology through
the looking-glass critical and
photography in the margins of Europe a
place in history social and monumental
time in a Cretan town the social
production of indifference the symbolic
roots of Western bureaucracy and the
last of his Greek books because he has
quite a few more portrait of a Greek
imagination and ethnographic biography
of andreas Netaji's now these books have
established his reputations as the
intellectual Trailblazer of Greek
anthropology and he has placed Greece at
the center of his discipline and
expanded its traditional theoretical
boundaries you can even tell from a last
title of the book and ethnographic
biography which is probably was unique
at its time he's a restless and
inquisitive scholar he's been taking
notes while we were talking by the way
so be careful of what you say she
oriented the focus of ours a he has
expanded the traditional theoretical
boundaries he's a restless and
inquisitive scholar he has oriented
since the last book on Greece his focus
on Italy on the dislocation and
gentrification of the district of Monti
in Rome and more recently has turned to
the question of bureaucratic practices
topic he explored in one of his previous
books in an entirely new country learned
an entirely new language of which she
speaks many with the study of an end
of partying cave of palm Moroccan I'm
not slaughtering the Thai language in
Bangkok and whose residents have heard a
quarter of a century I resisted
bureaucratic attempts for them to vacate
the district he's talked today and I
hope I'm not revealing anything too
secret especially with the title it's a
comparison of the cryptic colonial
analogies of Greece and Thailand which
in a sense brings his intellectual
legacy to full circle coming back to
Greece through Thailand more recently
his research includes a completion of a
book and a film about historic
conservation and eviction in Bangkok and
his new research focuses on Italian
Chinese interactions in Rome
and I believe he also has a short film
out two short films there you go and and
and when the profession of Town Planning
in Italy and elsewhere now he's also
been the president of the modern Greek
Studies Association I believe it was a
graduate student at the time and he has
also been the president of the Society
of the Anthropology of Europe has served
as added or co-editor or member of the
board over the datoria board in numerous
academic journals he is also the
recipient of a number of awards and in
his field research has been funded by
the National Endowment of the humanities
that John Simon Guggenheim Memorial
Foundation and a host of others and I
will skip a little bit the list so that
it doesn't sound like a list and in 1997
he was selected as fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
now those are the scholarly achievements
you can find them on his website and you
can read the books but I want to say a
few words about Michael Hertzfeld the
man the mentor and the scholar and I'm
speaking here because I do know the
people he has worked with and I know
what they have said to me among his
peers and students he is famous for his
general
prosody his Congeniality and his
inexhaustible enthusiasm he has been the
adviser of some of the most accomplished
younger anthropologists excelling today
in greek anthropology and has mentored
and supported scholars well beyond the
call of duty and of his own discipline
he is beloved by his colleagues and menu
and most of us and most of all by the
communities he has worked in for the
respect and dignity with which he
approached approaches his subjects so
it's only fitting that I should work in
him today
with a few words from the island which
considers him one of his own miss Denise
terminada
my family liPuma buona sera
Oh Sammy yes Dominus adieu me copa de la
verga Zoomer ya Metra the Metro man the
filler master bistec Oh is the million
Akuma and I hope you don't respond with
something improvised because I won't be
able to the same time those were a few
words from
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much indeed sigue sigue
automata movie Metro tada ciccolo throat
cinema Paramus Chitina Camaro No
so that's probably the best I could do
it's not very improvised but after a
couple of class idea we can maybe
improve the the performance so thank you
very much for having me
many thanks to the foundation and to the
program it's a great honor to be asked
to give this lecture and very special
for me because this is actually my last
semester in harness as I like to call it
at Harvard and thank you your row for
those very moving words so I'm going to
read most of the paper but there will be
some asides which from a really
entertaining part and we'll see how that
goes
besides I have to look like a professor
and that means glasses in the July of
2017 I gave a keynote address at the
international high studies conference in
Chiang Mai Thailand with the title
Thailand in a larger universe now I
wonder if you have any an idea of where
these columns are I might be able to
help you guess by showing you the next
slide these are the two slides from
which the poster was made and he takers
anyone want to guess where they are this
is a bit of a giveaway if you think of
the size of the columns but I'll come
back to the other one nobody dares I
don't blame you Bangkok and you'll see
why this is significant in a little
while but that day in Chiang Mai the
audience which in many ways reminded me
of similar occasions in Greece during
the hundred years of 1967 74 had a fair
number of police and military personnel
since the core of my address
subsequently published in the Journal of
Asian Studies was focused on a
comparison of the current military
dictatorship in Thailand and the Greek
winter of 40 years earlier I was
somewhat surprised
by the lack of reaction and perhaps a
little disappointed it occurs to me now
that the reason for the passive
reception of an argument that trot
dangerously close to the flashpoint of
military temper in Thailand today was
the mention of grief one could almost
see them thinking what's this got to do
with us why is he talking about Greece
this is a Thai Studies conference one
good reason for talking about Greece in
a dictatorship like that of Thailand
today is that dictatorship is an
experience the two countries have shared
following on civil conflicts embedded in
the logic of Cold War ideological
hostility in such close parallel that
they ended up with some very similar
assumptions for example the idea that
communism was far on Dogma say no
LogMeIn in in in Greek but you get the
same expression in Thai and was
antithetical to the freedom-loving
character of the people freedom and
death is a phrase you feel here in both
languages and the word tie itself is
sometimes mistranslated as free we
forget of course that the Vietcong also
thought they were fighting for freedom
but that's beside the point for the
moment there is however a huge
difference between the two countries
if Thailand has not only reverted to
military rule but is arguably
experiencing it in a more repressive
form than ever before Greece can now
look back on nearly half a century
longer even than we've known each other
of relatively successful and cumulative
experiment experimentation with
democratic governance while perhaps
Greece has not reached the point where
as South Korea another successful
escapee from military rule has done they
can impose severe penalties on
politicians caught cheating the public
over major financial matters Greece has
held demonstrably clean elections and if
political patronage still plays a role I
think patronage is a much better term
and much less value-laden than
corruption that patronage reproduces the
country between Greece as a whole and
its geopolitical patrons Germany France
the UK and the EU so Greece is now
embarked on a trajectory that takes it
far from the straightjacket in which
Thailand is still suffering and frankly
likely to continue
suffering for some time to come the
differences between the two countries
especially against this historical
backdrop are as revealing as the
similarities but both similarities and
differences are important I made the
argument then at that conference in
Chiang Mai that comparison far from
being a top-down instrument of colonial
management was in reality a highly
critical exercise one that pointed to
common causes as well as significant
differences and gave the lie to the
exceptionalism the view that we're
different from other countries that
ironically is one of the most obviously
shared features of Greece and Thailand
and I might say they do their
exceptionalism in remarkably similar
ways which is really the point of my
argument here so my willingness to
compare these two superficially very
different countries located
geographically far apart from each other
does call for some explication if only
because we need to break out of existing
assumptions about the Mediterranean and
Southeast Asia
I spent a large part of the early years
of my career trying to debunk the idea
of a Mediterranean culture you probably
were suffering through many of my
diatribes on the subject because I saw
even at that early point that for
example Greece and Italy had significant
differences which was in some ways much
more interesting than similarities and
of course we know that Greeks love to
say you know fat samyaza
which is very bad Italian because it
come out in Italians
meow faccia Mia that's us so they don't
rhyme in Italian and Italians find it
amazing when they go to Greece we'd like
to tell them these things the the point
precisely of this mediterráneo cameo is
that it shows in a way that the idea of
a Mediterranean culture is deeply rooted
and very important and that Greece in
the hierarchy of countries sees Italy as
somehow senior as more established as
richer and so on and so Greeks feel that
they want to claim some sort of identity
with this apparently more successful
country
same thing with Southeast Asia where in
many ways Thailand is the the motor that
drives a lot of the other economies in
fact the very idea of comparing two or
more countries
is offensive to those who reckon that
their own their own country is supposed
uniqueness exceptionalism makes the very
idea of such an operation absurd or
meaningless that's exactly what we mean
by exceptionalism
but even if nationalists accept some
muted form of comparison always of
course to the advantage of their own
country I think if I may say so
President Trump is a perfect example of
that you were waiting for me to mention
of Trump I think these days it's become
almost obligatory it must always rest on
two basic assumptions one that national
borders represent an int in frangible
ontology a physical realization of the
true extent of something called a
culture and understood to be eternal and
unchanging which any anthropologist will
tell you is nonsense but you try saying
that to a nationalist and to comparison
can only conjoin countries at the same
time kind so that while for example
comparing Greece and Italy could make
some sort of sense in terms of
pre-existing ideas about the glories of
Europe classical past comparing Greece
and Nigeria or claiming that Greece and
African countries shared a common
heritage contravenes that deeply rooted
hegemonic and counter evidential
conviction we call common sense as
people say it stands to reason that this
is impossible so say the Nationalists
thereby occluding the fact that reason
is the one thing that's not being
employed in such pre-emptive thinking
aside from the tragic relevance of this
pattern for the politics of race in
Europe and North America today again I
think we see a lot of it at the moment
in the run-up to the midterm elections
it's also the source of the deep
hostility encountered by Martin Bernard
book black Athena I'm not arguing that
but
Varnell was necessarily right since
neither am I come am I competent to make
such an assessment nor is it relevant to
the question of whether the everyday
critiques of his work were based on more
than the sheer horror that some
conservative Greeks taught that they
were the living ancestors of Europe felt
on hearing the news that a distinguished
scholar had claimed that their own
ancestors were African in quotes this
symbolic logic as opposed to
evidentially based reasoning is is very
clear we can show how it works by a
comparison that does indeed take Greeks
and Italy together by noting that in
Italy Africa always begins just south of
where the speaker lives so Rome Romans
will always well first of all
northerners will always say that Africa
begins in Rome in Rome they'll say
begins in Naples and in Sicily
well everybody thinks that Africa the
Naples will say it begins in Sicily so
this is a symbolic geography of
prejudice and it partakes is the same
symbolic logic that makes an African
ancestry for Greek culture something
that people will not reject on the base
of evidence which I think you could
actually do but will simply reject
because they feel that it violates their
culturally and ideologically
overdetermined understanding of common
sense in other words by suggesting a
comparison of Greece with Thailand I
probably seemed to those military men in
the audience to be talking harmless
nonsense
they were probably unaware of the
enthusiasm with which some mostly
left-wing Thai scholars had taken our
concept as I had articulated of crypto
colonialism a concept that has already
been mentioned by Jurgis but I'll bring
it up again later in the talk in Greece
when I first articulated the notion in
2002 that was met with what can only be
described as deafening silence but it
only began to break the silence in
Greece only began to break with the
increasing severity of the austerity
measures imposed by the troika around
2009 the issue is actually quite a
simple one that the very idea of
comparing Greece in Thailand also
violates an uncritical hierarchical and
hegemonic common sense of clearly
Western European inspiration though
perhaps not as egregiously as burnell's
comparison with Africa given that
Thailand is a bit higher up than a
generalized Africa in the global
hierarchy of cultural value created and
disseminated by the European colonial
powers and indeed it one piece of
evidence that Greece has a crypto colony
is the enthusiasm with which they've
embraced precisely this kind of
prejudicial Haraki nineteenth-century
travellers saw the ties or Siamese as
they were then as semi civilized whereas
they did not attribute civilization to
Africans at all and my argument is
precisely that some of the similarities
between Greece and Thailand are the
results of cultural management by the
colonial powers a process that
linguistic anthropologists call in
textual ization I'll define that for you
in a moment and that precisely because
it's dressed in all the panoply of
serious scholarship and buttress by the
wishful thinking of Europeans that
preserves the logic of social
evolutionism even as scholars today
reject its tenets as relics of colonial
power and Prejudice is one of the most
effective means of perpetuating ideas
about culture that have been used by
Western scholars to treat Greece with
condescension contempt and worse now let
me explain in text realization what
linguistic anthropologists mean by this
term is that you can have a say a set of
proverbs you put them into a volume of
folklore and you arrange them in a
certain order that will then suggest
that some of the cultural long sigh some
of the locations that are mentioned in
these connections are superior to others
and this was done all over the a
colonial world so scholars collected
folklore and used it essentially to
prove that some of the races as they
called them in India for example usually
lighter-skinned people often people
whose religious beliefs came closer to
those of the Christian English British
were somehow higher up in the scale and
therefore their proverbs their sayings
were given higher priority this is what
we mean by in textual ization and I've
applied the concept in one essay to the
way in which some of the 19th century
Greek folklore it's essentially did the
same thing some parts of Greece are
considered to be more civilized than
others so comparing Greece and Thailand
violates that carefully constructed
preset structure of prejudice that again
I've elsewhere called the global
hierarchy of
Greece's political and cultural
isolation so much of its history was
engineered by Western powers intent on
using Greece as a geographical political
and conceptual barrier against oriental
influences and so by treating Greece as
a sort of no-man's land between the west
and the rest and a place of dangerous
hybridity and contamination a place
where people claiming to be Europeans
could look suspiciously Turkish and
we're there for the symbolism of
corruption could be used to keep those
people locked in an alert in electable
logic of contempt that was what the
European colonial powers did to a
country they refused to call a colony
but they colonized it cryptically the
pattern continues to this day whereas in
the past the West used the metaphor of
contamination to treat modern Greek
everyday culture and folklore as the
detritus of a two million two millennia
long fall from from cultural grace today
for example it is German companies
including one that is actually part of
the Germans state that bribed Greek
bureaucrats and it was not so long ago
that American British and French
interests supported the planet ridden
politics of the Greek moderate
right-wing and served their interests
while accused the Greeks themselves of
being corrupt in other words to say to
our Greek saying what am i until China
have to confine me right if the trouble
starts at the top so it's also to use an
English proverb the kettle calling the
pot calling the kettle black because
just as for example Zeman's Daimler and
Deutsche Bahn which is part of the the
German state apparatus bribed various
Greek officials in order to get
preferential economic treatment so also
in earlier years it was Western
supported politicians whom the rest
wanted to keep very much in position who
maintained their own position by buying
votes and exchanging votes for favors so
for the West then to turn round and
accuse not only accused the Greeks of
being corrupt but also saying that this
was clearly the relic of something
Ottoman
when it was actually the relic of
something very European and very
Colonials is I think a piece of arrogant
hypocrisy the other things interesting
about these terms corruption and
contamination if there are
anthropologists in the audience you will
recognize immediately that these are
examples of what the British
anthropologist as long ago as 1966
pointed out was what considered dirt in
every culture is not necessarily
biologically dirty at all it's matter
out of place to use her phrase and the
idea that somehow elements that were not
part of the ancient of the ancient
literary tradition could creep into the
folklore was treated as contamination in
the same way as the idea that you know
good clean politicians shouldn't be
accepting bribes was also seen as a
contamination of the Greek spirit so
again we see the engineering of a
portrait of the Greeks are very negative
portrait of the Greeks by the Western
powers used to keep the Greeks in that
very crucial place as the buffer zone
between the west and the rest so
comparisons that violate for them are
slogic of Cartesian thought and communal
power alike are likely to be met with
derision a defensive division to the
extent that many Greeks feel that if
they allow comparisons of Greeks with
Asian for which read either Persian in
the ancient world or Turkish in the
modern world right with Asian countries
they will be confirming the prejudice
with which the powerful Western states
have treated them hence the deafening
silence that initially greeted my
attempt to compare Greece with Thailand
but in fact one of the main reasons for
the persistence of assumptions about
incommensurability between such
countries is precisely the global
dynamic that for me makes these two
countries particularly comparable this
is the phenomenon that I call crypto
colonialism and I will define it very
simply crypto colonialism is a condition
in which a country is for all practical
purposes treated as a colony but it is
told that it is independent and it has
to exercise its independence in
accordance with the dictates of the
colonial power
those of you who know Greek history will
immediately know what I'm talking about
and if you know anything about Thailand
Nepal Afghanistan Iran Iraq Ethiopia
before the Italian invasion we could go
on the list is quite long am i I'm
actually trying to work on a book about
crypto colonialism because I think it is
quite a useful concept people sometimes
say yes but all the things you describe
or what you find in post colonies and I
say yes but that's the point these
countries say they're not post colonies
as a result they can't join the
post-colonial grumbling Club they don't
get any sympathy at all and they end up
being shunned by both sides so Greece
really is between a rock and a hard
place which makes the story I'm going to
tell even more remarkable way that it
seems to have managed to get itself out
of that difficult situation so now let
me explore the cultural consequences of
this jail for the Racal situation that's
an important backdrop to what follows
and then I'll suggest a relationship
between the growing resistance to that
situation by Greeks who in another age
might have been very much in thrall to
the crypto colonial system on the one
hand their new perspectives comes comes
as a part I suggest of the emergence of
Greece as arguably one of the world's
most vibrant democracies today a country
that has managed to countenance
significant ideological alternation
which i think is the mark of a healthy
democratic discussion along with forms
of solidarity that seemed to contradict
the conventional concept of Greek
society as hopelessly Agron istic
quarrelsome
and well Vulcan because another one of
those prejudices which was put around
during the Yugoslav war in particular is
look you know these Balkan peoples are
all just hopelessly quarrelsome they
always have these terrible feuds yes
well if we look at who instigated a lot
of the feuding and certainly scale the
feuding up so it became ethno
nationalists fighting it becomes very
easy to see what the logic is now
there's an important lesson here for
social anthropologists as much as for
political scientists although I would
venture to suggest that the political
scientists would have done well to read
a few ethnographies in order to
understand how the rhetoric of death
or craves and obligation which means
being under a debt in greek epoch lousy
right has played out as the scale of
contest has moved upward from local
village quarrels with their little
recognized mechanisms for conciliation
in crete for example there is a very
well-developed way of reconciling people
who'd been enemies called s-- as most
from a verb sossel and i pull it
straight but it's very ritualistic so
even in these places the famous
villagers on your now which is actually
where i now admit openly I did my
fieldwork they the the level of actual
homicidal violence is very low because
everybody knows what the consequences of
a few are and therefore people rush to
try to bring the feuding people together
this is important it seems to me for
understanding how Greeks now react to
being bullied by Germany and other
countries and it's also equally
important to see the whole notion of
people creo C as underlying the way the
Greeks are responding to the sovereign
debt issue so as I say I think it would
be useful if political scientists if I
may say so economists would read a few
ethnographies because I think they would
see a lot more of the internal
mechanisms here so we talk about the EU
as a group of partners which
theoretically means that they're equals
more often however in Greece they are
feared and resented as colonial powers
bent on new forms not only of
humiliation but also extraction the
Daniel Knight and Nicholas Argenti have
done very interesting research for
example on how in a village in in towns
in Thessaly and elsewhere and also on
the island of Chios German companies
come in create very productive voltaic
photovoltaic cell clusters as a way of
extracting clean energy they're so
successful that they take all the clean
energy away with them as it were they
siphon it off to Germany and the
villagers now are left having to burn
wood which of course is totally wrecking
their environment so this is extraction
with an added problem created by weight
the former that it takes now we won't
understand the dynamics of Greek German
relations in particular unless we also
recall the role the German scholars long
before they had a United Nations state
of their own
played in generating both the concept of
the nation Helder of course was an
important influence here and the
peculiar image of ancient Greece
actually not ancient Greece at all but
rather distorted view of 5th century BC
Attica which is a much more parochial
affair begin with in shaping some would
say warping the development of Greek
national identity ever since and even
before 1821 oops ok I just put this
slide and parenthetically to keep in
mind that we are thinking about a
comparison and I'm sure you recognize
the on the left but on the right this is
the current Prime Minister of Thailand
and what's ironic is here at
Papadopoulos wearing a uniform with the
crown of a monarchy that he actually got
rid of and pray it is certainly locked
in some kind of sinister combat with the
current king of Thailand but nobody
dares talk about it now I'm going to
make some mention of a German
scholarship it was absolutely vital in
building the picture of ancient Greece
and many of you will know the name of
Inca man of course but there were also
German philologists who were involved in
the same kinds of activities more
familiarly one of the ironies may think
this is a perfect illustration of crypto
colonialism notice that these F zones
are actually marching with a step that
is prohibited in its country of origin
namely Germany because it's associated
with the kind of militarism that began
with the Prussians and reached its worst
metastasis I guess with the Nazis now
this is time and then we'll come back to
that at a moment just leave that there
I'm going to leave you guessing a little
bit what's go
in that particular document that will
we'll come to it
so Percy Shelley's infamous line Fair
grease sad relic of departed worth set
the term for two centuries of curiously
miss named Phil Hellenism they own thing
for somebody who loves the country to
say about it after all it was miss named
because while paying formal respect to
the ideals of the classical heritage
that they'd largely invented for
themselves those who called themselves
felons were actually party to and indeed
the most comfortable party to a process
of cultural humiliation that I'm arguing
has generated in Greece a sense of
hermetic defensiveness for which then
these self-appointed felons mock the
Greeks though then again you see we
create a victim and then we we attack
the victim we criticize the victim I
shall also argue today that today as
Greece finds in its humiliation at the
hands of the powerful European nations
the means and stimulus for rethinking
the roles that those nations of Science
degrees in their own vision of world
history there is a risk of repeating the
most dangerous mistake of the past the
assumption that Greece is unique in this
respect and that's why we need to keep
thinking about some other places while
all countries process certain features
that are indeed unique it is what we
broadly recognizes their cultural
characteristics the similarities I'll
suggest are the product of global
processes that include claims the
difference to being unique and that
again is the phenomenon we call
exceptionalism
now when Barack Obama went to Greece he
paid tribute to its role as the
birthplace of democracy and your chair
professor Geena Conference of course
just it the same thing I'm going to beg
to differ I think it's unfortunate and
symptomatic of the ignorance with which
much of the Western world reads Greek
history that what he meant was 5th
century BC in Athens the place that by
modern standards wouldn't have been much
of a democracy at all with its extensive
slave population and it's perhaps
unthinking because culturally embedded
denial of women's suffrage had he
instead pointed to 1981 and the
election of Andreas Papandreou not so
much an anti-american as a politician
who dared to speak Greek truth to
American power as the moment when Greece
passed the acid test of democracy by
electing an opposition party to
parliamentary power he would have been
far closer to some sort of fundamental
understanding of political reality and
he would have struck a decisive blow
against the real subjugation of Greece
not to the miss named to khakhra Tia
which should really be called Ottoman or
Katya because it was actually quite
insulting to anyone who spoke Turkish to
be called a cook in those days but to a
German generated antiquarianism that
masked in respectable archaeological and
fill illogical terms the British and
French project of colonizing the Greek
mind now there were to be sure in Greece
even in earlier days critics of this
model I mentioned a few names and honest
minutos as early as 1850 objected to the
way that folklorists nationalists
folklorists was simply twisting songs
that they could fit them into this
paradigm George lumpy not Jurgis
lumbering Norse during the Cold War
again doing much the same thing and
arguing that it was nonsense to call the
the epic poems about the Unison Akitas
national because they're nothing to do
with the nation-state which only came
into being for the first time arguably
as late as 1835 for but certainly no
earlier than 1821 just as the dominance
of Cartesian thinking drained drowned
out the radical critique of descartes by
Giambattista Vico who was himself later
co-opted as a nationalist emblem people
really amazing how people can take over
a critic and make him one of their own
so to the few voices that have dared
challenge the dominance of the
neoclassical paradigm were often ignored
actively suppressed or even again
co-opted today however their
intellectual heirs are in the ascendant
and this coincides as I'm suggesting
with the achievement of something we can
recognize as a successfully participate
or a democracy question what happened
what has happened I think is that the
combination of participate ori democracy
with severe economic pressure from
outside the country has allowed the
greeks to scale up their sense of
agonistic engagement greeks do not
consider arguing with somebody an insult
and I've been struck many many times by
the way in which Greeks will turn an
initially negative interaction into a
positive one indeed my friends and Sonia
now steal sheep from each other in order
as they say to make friends you can't
respect somebody who won't steal your
sheep and that may sound ridiculous but
then you know I find also even in Athens
among very sophisticated academics some
of the same attitude I have a big
argument first and then we go out
drinking together because we've resolved
our argument through mutual respect so
for Greeks
agonism is not the sign of disrespect
it's a sign of respect and it is really
important to go back to the early
ethnographies where this is made very
clear in a very simple form because it
appears of course as a component of
village life and I'll give you a perfect
expression of it from Sonia now man said
to me one day I'm either not gonna need
to save any see crisis if you don't feel
some sense of stress you can't possibly
relax now many Americans would not
understand that and certainly a lot of
Brits wouldn't understand it but this is
in a way the expression of these
countervailing sentiments and I'll show
how that plays out first however an
explanation about what's going on here I
wanted to show you that Greece was not
alone in having been also more or less
forced to adopt Western styles of dress
and especially Western modes of
respectability in Greece is what this
was very directly tied to the idea of
the control of the body and it was given
a classical lineage in Thailand which
had no connection with the classical
world as such it was a simple imitation
of the West so on the Left we have the
way the ties were this is from somewhere
in the 1930s they think under the
dictatorship of martial people Thailand
has a very long history of dictatorship
on the right is the way they're supposed
to look and this continues today so as
their excuse
for now sadly totally destroying the
community of Papa haka and that Jurgis
was kind enough to mention it's
disappeared completely they gave us this
image of a respectable Park and this is
the kind of people they imagine using it
they don't even look Thai let alone
working class and therefore have nothing
to do with people who were living there
Greece has somehow managed to turn away
from that attitude you will still find
people of a certain political stripe who
believe that the Western models are
ideal and so on but it's I think most
people have a strong consciousness that
this is cultural engineering at its
worst and so that's also part of the
story that I'm telling now we return to
Greece and what I want to tell you about
is the role of archaeology because
archaeology was the ocular given fear
the archaeological service was a state
within the state for decades a very
powerful institution because it was the
instrument of the articulation of
Western European interests with the
creation of Greece as a model based on
the ancient world as it was imagined in
the West
this is Demeter esplen source I nearly
said this was but that would have been a
nice irony because what I'm about to say
to you relate to you as a conversation I
had with plans us which I think actually
shows you how far archaeologists and he
is an archaeologists have come there's a
whole new generation now ganas can be
like these who recently moved to the
states and teachers at Brown
Demetrios Flanders and several others
who are tearing apart that old concept
because they want to expose the ways in
which it was used and one day I said to
planters you know I think Greece should
I that Britain should give the Elgin
marbles to Greece I did not give them
back because they never belonged to
Greece this isn't one of the myths right
they belonged they were the property the
personal property of person had the land
a Turkish actually Ottoman particular
speaking aha
in Athens who sold them to Lord Elgin
for the most part the locals both
Turkish speaking in Greek speaking were
using the marbles to grind them up to
make mortar so alguien was saving them
in any case for posterity but I didn't
want to defend that line I simply wanted
to say it's time that Britain gave them
Elgin marbles to grace as a sign that
Britain was no longer interested in
exercising colonial domination of a
Greece and plans have said no I don't
agree with you
Greece will be free when the British
offer us the marbles and we say it's
okay think you can keep them I thought
that really was a remarkable moment for
me that shows you how far the pendulum
has now swung in the other direction
it's an age in which the current prime
minister mr. tsipras
can offer a potentially viable solution
to the thorny Macedonian issue which
again would probably never have been an
issue but for the way in which the West
found the flames of neoclassicism in
Greece and we could go on with lots of
other examples the carretera protests
that actually planned was written about
where the image of the chorus was used
as a symbol not of obedience to the
classical norms but of resistance to the
government and I think I have a yes now
we are from Athens you can see it's
Batsy wooden yeah you know thugs and
pigs so this is how we deal with the
classical past when we're being beaten
up by police who are seen as operating
on behalf of the wealthy the bankers and
so on and again of the Western
especially German interests and of
course there's the famous critique
playing young economy lackeys of the and
the archaeologist who excavated the
tombs are very you know
Manolis Andronicus Herman Locke is
called Andronicus his highly popular
journalism counter modern by which I
take it it means that this journalism
attempted to sustain or perhaps
resuscitate the old crypto colonial Cold
War and
standing of the relevance and
significance of the ancient past common
lack is more away explicitly ties this
antiquarianism to the colonialism to
conquered the Greek mind through the
device paradoxically of nationalism
Camille Angus departs slightly from my
position in suggesting that Greece was
not a crypto colony but a true colony in
which we see effects that are very much
like those we find in genuine post
colonies I would argue instead as I did
a moment ago that the whole idea of
crypto colonialism was the show that you
get colonial effects in societies that
claim never to have been colonized and
this at least were an accord but that
these effects are much harder for crypto
colonies than for post colonies to
address for the very simple and
compelling reason that they cannot admit
that these are the effects of
colonization at all because that would
go against the nationalist mess of
Independence what makes it all the more
remarkable that the archaeologists
should be in the vanguard of a critique
is the fact that as I say archaeologists
were really the strongest intellectual
supporters along with the folklorists of
the Nationalists the ethno nationalists
ideal when I was doing research in
retinoid Crete
one of the worst swear words you could
ever hear was actually a year it was
really a bad word because the accurate
ocular here which was a short way of
saying accuracy panacea archaeological
service was considered to be an invasive
presence that had nothing to do with the
everyday lives of the people of the town
they were seen as enemies of ordinary
people even though those same ordinary
people fought as coming like if Senor
Looney have shown to stop their
antiquities from being carted off for
exhibition in Athens didn't like the
idea that Creek nante cookies would be
taken for exhibition in Athens so
there's tension within the system as
well now here the archaeologists and I'm
in total agreement with coming like it's
on this point were entrusted with the
ongoing task of providing a national
historical charter for the Greek people
in that context Andronicus was played a
pivotal role in shaping public opinion
in generating public excitement this was
not a trivial task this was internal
propaganda on a very big scale but the
point is that what archaeology
could manufacture it could also unravel
and as the official discourse that had
held the drink imagination in thrall to
orientalist the neoclassical phonology
and archeology began to lose its grip on
an emergent generation of
internationally educated younger Greeks
some daring archaeologists coming
lackeyson plans most prominent among
them began to point to the subversive
possibilities of new interpretations of
the ancient past liberating both their
discipline and a significant portion of
public opinion from the unbearable
weight of a carefully crafted image of
the past now in Thailand held back from
such developments on the ongoing pretext
of saving the monarchy from the
paradoxically conjoined evils of
communism and consumerism very strange
such daring revisionism was and is a
virtual impossibility for local scholars
and it's been the task of foreigners for
themselves privileged by the dynamic
crypto colonialism to open up the
critiques this doesn't mean that local
scholars won't follow suit it's what
happened after all in Greece the
criticism began to certain extent with
foreigners but it will take time and
while such changes can also trigger
political change they tend to follow it
and the army or the military are very
much in charge at the moment Thailand
has an additional problem and that's the
role of China the ultimate censor with
its now globally expanding Great
Firewall in fact China is now very
assiduously taking control over much of
the political process in Thailand and in
fact most of the rest of Southeast Asia
as well just today I came across a
recent article by an anonymous author
who claims to have independently
invented the term crypto Coloma
colonialism and uses it to describe the
creeping annexation of Southeast and and
Central Asia by China through its
cultural and economic expansion ISM via
the belt and road initiative when
there's an irony there because I think
China itself is a crypto colony in some
respects and it's not you know that some
countries are in some countries are not
there are degrees of being a crypto
colony I think well if the term works
here well I'm good
in Thailand the Chinese will discover a
population already
accustomed to crypto colonial rule and
perhaps not so sure it wants to repeat
the experience under a new master China
itself has suffered the effects of trip
to colonialism however and we may be
sure that it will export the idea under
the guise of new forms of essentialism
and exceptionalism reviving the old
orientalist fantasy of an Asia so
different from what also
undifferentiated West as to be
unrecognizable in its many varied parts
many Thais already talked blaze Li about
the West in precisely these very
generalizing terms here the closest
analogy with rhesus perhaps Taiwan the
self-declared island Republic that
defies the Authority and even the
nationalist rhetoric of mainland China
which treats it as a mere province and a
wayward one at that Taiwan like South
Korea has replaced internal dictatorship
with a functioning democracy that much
of the annoyance of the mainland
encourages ideological alternation
including alternation on the question of
whether Taiwan is really Chinese at all
it's celebration of its Japanese
colonial heritage and its preservation
of antiquities of kinds that were mostly
obliterated on the mainland during the
Cultural Revolution
are particularly obnoxious in the eyes
of the Communist Party
it is also perhaps not coincidentally
both Greece and Taiwan's will rapid
growth in the discipline of social and
cultural anthropology during this time
we are part of what we study and
anthropologists are very used to
recognizing this in Greece especially
thanks to the efforts of anchors
pappataci artist University of the
Aegean or mytilini and they may target
from where they I knew at the pond do
there was a sudden upsurge of interest
in the discipline and for a while and to
some extent still it's been very popular
in undergraduates much more so I might
say that in the u.s. this is also not
coincidentally anthropology is almost by
definition of Convention challenging
discipline the experience of fieldwork a
virtual guarantee that its practitioners
will always be uncomfortable with both
essentialism and exceptionalism for
anthropologists all self-proclaimed
national cultures are in some sense
exceptional that is in terms of their
specific cultural content it is their
exceptionality so to speak that is
unexceptional but some are more
Exceptionalist than others Greece
desperately hanging on to the threads
dignity conferred on it by the grudging
recognition of its ancient past in the
past was I'm fine a say so
exceptionally exceptionally and it would
be sad if today the country were to
relapse into that fundamentally very
lonely condition Greece can do much
better for itself and certainly has done
so in recent years in the face of
extraordinary pressures from so-called
friends so now I turn briefly back to
the Thai example to see if possible in
the Thai way that we can find in the
Prai use of archaeology some further
insight into how and why the Thai Park
diverged so dramatically from that taken
by Greece in general archaeology has not
been a highly developed discipline in
Thailand part of the reason for this is
a relative lack of interest in
materiality as Dennis burners
demonstrated conservationists for
interest for example are less concerned
with recovering original materials than
with aesthetic standards it's no
coincidence that the equivalent of the
Greek archaeological service in Thailand
is the equally tyrannical fine arts
department I think that's a significant
difference of naming and unlike Greeks
who've learned to glory in ancient ruins
ties are generally more interested in
adorning existing statues and temples
with gold and glitter than with any idea
of preserving original materials from
the past
thus a certain passivity with regard to
archaeological activity both protects
the standard narrative and provides very
little space for developing an
alternative story so I should be drawing
this somewhat to a close and I just want
to mention very very briefly that in
Thailand there was one major excavation
from which most of the pottery some
beautiful prehistoric pottery at the
place called ban Chang had disappeared
and was squirreled away mostly by
American servicemen there's a very
sinister story behind all of this I
don't have time to go into detail but
let me just say this that that
excavation was encouraged both by the
royally supported Thai finance
department and by the Americans but
the Americans thought okay if we could
persuade the Thais that there is such an
ancient civilization here and that they
can connect themselves to it then they
will have an added reason for resisting
the advantage of all those foreign
communists in Laos and Vietnam and
Cambodia overlooking the fact that
Cambodian language actually has
infiltrated especially the royal
language of Thailand and that Lao is in
fact a variant of the same language
family with time so the the this the
Cold War was if we like the final
intensification for both countries of
this very beholden condition that I've
been describing now the story of
Greece's return to democracy is quite
remarkable part of the story lies in the
appalling but fortunate incompetence of
the Colonel's whose adventurism in
Cyprus was that me a major factor to
other factors are perhaps a little more
surprising one was the deck aft or key
moment the 18 tech which I think raised
consciousness very quickly and also made
fun of the Colonel's because as VanDyke
points out in her book Cassandra and the
sensors but I literally going along with
a law which said that a book has to have
a title which describes its contents and
calling the contents 18 texts they
forced the Colonel's to allow them to
publish what was in fact a series of
satire about dictatorship and that
really began to get people thinking and
talking the other was the students of
the Polytechnic University of Athens
their uprising which occurred exactly
one month after the students at Thomas
Knight University in Bangkok had risen
against a dictatorship there and
actually brought it to its knees and
with the result that Thailand did then
enjoy a three-year period of democracy
it took Greece another year and the
stupidity of the regime in it
interference in Cyprus to break
everything up but Greece had one piece
of extraordinary fortune and I'm not the
reliever
the one man theory of history but the
arrival of Konstantinos Karamanlis at
the crucial moment I think was extremely
important to get a transition from
military dictatorship that the military
by and large would accept it was
absolutely essential to bring somebody
in that they respected and could under
no circumstances imagine might be a
communist the fact that he then
legalized the Communist Party had
another referendum that more decisively
abolished the monarchy and quickly got
rid of the use of Cather ever so for all
our official purpose is and then it was
too late for the military to do anything
but I think the most intelligent thing
he did was to make sure that his
successor as party leader and prime
minister was a political incompetent the
son of a Nazi sympathizer man called
ureas riley's who had no way of winning
an election against the extraordinarily
charismatic Andreas Papandreou
Papandreou father had been Karamanlis
his nemesis in 1963 so the whole idea
here it seems to be that somehow while
he was away if I may say so studying
social sciences Karamanlis had some sort
of epiphany and understood that the acid
test of a democracy was that the
opposition would win and he succeeded so
well you may not like some of the
parties that come to power whether it's
the right wing like in criteria or
whether it's a relatively left-wing
party of tea press but notice what
happens Andreas Papandreou comes in with
a new Socialist Party that not been in
existence for very long wins an election
starts to look too much like the old man
gratia party collapses there's suddenly
a new left-wing so you get real
ideological alternation and I think we
can credit if not Carlin is himself
certainly what he represented and so I
sometimes wonder whether there's anyone
like that who can be found for Thailand
and I actually would make a suggestion
that there was such a person
tragically a Muslim and former foreign
minister and secretary-general of a
sensor in Pizza Wan and so a personal
friend of mine he sadly died of a heart
attack very suddenly last year and a lot
of people I think thought that that was
a chance for tonight to have its own
kind of monies because them the times
create sometimes that the the context in
which somebody who doesn't seem like
such an exceptional politician seizes
the opportunity de Klerk in South Africa
was such a man he seemed to be rather a
humdrum politician not very inspiring
even to his own side but he had the
genius to seize the moment and I think
that we should be careful not to dismiss
these people even juan carlos in spain
although there that the myth may have
been a little bit more manufactured but
it's interesting to think about these
conservative leaders who actually
enabled transition to very
unconservative political developments so
meanwhile one of greece countries are
not always destined to be permanently
weak or strong we forget that before
world war ii for example sweden was one
of the poorest countries in europe the
little Englanders who are holding
Theresa May hostage right now maybe
sending Britain or perhaps England going
it alone down the state down the rivers
path or should I say down the drain
Greece hitherto both poor and marginal
may yet assume a more dominant role
because not in spite of the fact that
it's worship of antiquity its actual
area is starting to fade and with its
long-standing dependence on great power
interests and German scholarship such
trajectories are always and everywhere
unstable the danger degrees now comes
from a relapse into exceptionalism the
reversion to dependence on a contrived
antiquity a nun furniture as the sources
of the country's legitimacy not only
with such a development involved the
return of a repressive historiography
but much more dangerously it would bring
with it scaling down to lower levels of
contestation and a possible decline in
the new civility all of that talk about
solidarity both with migrants and with
each other among Greeks the
present circumstances do seem to have
generated as the case of the United
Kingdom demonstrates this could also
result in enormous damage to a country's
international standing as well as to an
unraveling of its own traditions of
democratic governments one way of
avoiding such a collapse I suggest is to
bring comparison more effectively into
the study of modern Greece to some
extent that's already happened for what
I've been able to do with the example of
Thailand others can certainly do with
other countries and perhaps do it more
systematically many years ago I heard
spiros arion is arguing that modern
Greek scholars needed to learn about
Turkey and other places as hystyried
histories had intersected with without
of grease his prescient recommendations
which must have shocked and angered some
of his hearers at the time have
certainly since then been realized
albeit rather half-heartedly in some
cases around the eastern Mediterranean
and in southern Europe but I don't only
mean comparison with adjacent countries
peoples and political systems I also
mean some of the less obvious pairings
with India for example where much of
what we view as typically Mediterranean
cultural traits is filtered through
radically different religious traditions
and experiences when I went to study at
Oxford I couldn't study with John
Campbell my eventual advisor the first
year so I was I was sent to study with
Ravindra Jain an Indian scholar of India
and within one year I was convinced that
India must be part of the Mediterranean
they had honor and shame they had
kinship systems that in some respects
resembled those of parts of the
Mediterranean I could go on and on about
the similarities there are historical
connections of course but my point is
precisely that the further away you get
geographically the more interesting that
comparisons become and this is what I'm
trying to do with this kind of exercise
I mean above all to celebrate what might
be taken as outrageous comparisons that
just because they are outrageous defy
exceptionalism which is after all pretty
outrageous itself but recognize
exceptions that work against the
powerful prejudices that animates so
much of the racism that still
surreptitiously in fact infest our
scholarship and that shocked us into
realizing how little we actually know it
takes hard work
long hours of study and long months of
fieldwork the giddy terror of learning
completely unrelated in difficult
languages my Thai teacher asking me to
say how do you say is your house near or
far the difference between near and far
entire play okay so and travel travel
travel and get more travel some of my
friends think that my dhamma CEO is
actually United Airlines but we have a
chance today to turn the study of modern
Greece into a much more exciting space
and thereby also to participate in the
Vipers vibrancy of its body politic to
enjoy its newly democratized
institutions and to understand that the
difficult with faces it has turned
already in some cases into advantages
for today and Greeks for the first time
in centuries in counter cultural others
on mass as migrants and discover new
forms of civility and solidarity in
themselves as a result they're comparing
not on the basis of ignorant prejudiced
but on the basis of intimate knowledge
scholars should thus follow the example
of ordinary people and abandon the
stereotypes of yesteryear scholars have
been responsible for many of those
stereotypes it's time for us to take the
lead in dismantling them Thailand has
taught me a lot about Greece and Greece
about Thailand just as the heroes of the
Polytechnic learned from the students of
Thomas Art University in Bangkok we can
learn from Thailand's current
experiences to understand more fully the
huge step that Greece has taken toward a
truly civil society and the challenges
and possibilities that as a result
Greece will increasingly face moving
forward this comparison should not be an
exercise in schadenfreude but on the
contrary a genuine recognition that once
upon a time Greece was facing something
very much like what Thailand is facing
today much as today Greek empathy for
migrants when it occurs and it because
surprisingly often compared especially
with what happens in some other
countries especially here Springs from
the recognition that Greeks too have
often been unhappy so dinners in foreign
and distant lands at the very least
performing such a comparison we will
realize how fortunate Greece is today to
have escaped the vicious cycle of
oppression and while there is still
progress yet to be made for example in
the area of minority rights how truly
it's energetic achievements are better
understood in terms of the world as it
is today then as some sort of pale
reflection of an air that's past
exceptionalism is a form of escapism a
bearing one's hand in the sand of
parochial vision better I suggest to
recognize that we're all human beings we
are all Anthropy within that
encompassing identity comparison
encourages the tender nurturing of
diversity and civility of respect for
the dignity of the different and it
warns us away from the brink of the
disaster that exceptionalism has always
that everywhere everywhere brought to
its exponents no way I'm also in fact
that in that country that on until
recently one always had to shout modern
for modern Greece as opposed to what we
should ask every time his name was
mentioned how many other countries had
to call themselves modern in order even
to be recognized comparison as a
critical tool allows us to work away
from the conceptual repression of the
global hierarchy of value and to
appreciate the grace of today not from
what it never was but for what at this
moment it is thank you
absolutely well thank you for that
wonderful and provocative talk it ranged
all over the world might even say it was
all over the place I think I understood
your main point but I have a question
about it I think you were arguing that
the myth of ancient Greek exceptionalism
created by German scholars and all and
other Westerners was used to colonize
Greece as it were crypto colonized
Greece so I was wondering if you could
apply that to the current Greek
predicament the way Greece has gotten
itself into the grip of the Germans as
you would say is through its debt did
somehow this ancient Greek
exceptionalism lead Greece into debt is
that part of your argument I would I
would actually it's an interesting
question but I would flip it the other
way around and in fact this is what part
of what I was trying to say that the
current German treatment of Greece is
certainly a continuation of what was
happening before it's a form of
condescension basically that also takes
the plot the the the the form of ripping
the country off whether it's just the
Germans or the Germans the British and
the French all together I mean there's a
long history of this the example I gave
for example of the people in Thessaly
who actually talk about their
experiences as a form of colonialism and
also make very disparaging references to
the German occupation during World War
two so I would argue that what happened
was the Greece was weakened in the 19th
century by its dependence on this image
of ancient Greece which among other
things led it into one of these rather
pointless arguments about the name of
Macedonia and so on that wouldn't have
mattered to the Greeks if they hadn't
been
so dependent on that ancient myth and
Greece and sir Germany has certainly
exploited that and Germans have never
been unwilling to say look you know you
Greeks just don't live up to the
standards of your ancient forbears after
all they created their image of the
ancient forbears but i think that it's
not some residual element of ancient
greek values that is that is making the
greeks respond in the way they do the
concept of debt is certainly very old
even say it's traditional in Greece the
notion of obligation and the obligation
to repay debt malthael most at the
beginning of as you surely know the
beginning of the 20th century argued
that in all societies in fact any kind
of of transfer of property the form of a
gift or pro station creates a reciprocal
obligation and he developed his whole
theory of reciprocity on that basis it
seems to me that the Western powers have
very cleverly managed to create a
situation in which Greece has been
economically beholden to them they have
squeezed Greece as hard as they could
because it was very convenient and
economically quite worthwhile for them
to do so at various points and not so
much economically but politically and
militarily and now Greece has begun to
turn around
and say all right we will accept from a
weak position as you rightly say we will
accept a certain amount of regulation
but I suspect but they're going to start
turning the tables on the more powerful
countries first of all Britain is almost
certainly going to slide into
destitution if they go through with
brexit now that's a whole other story
but Germany seems to be teetering on the
brink of a far-right takeover which will
not only be a political disaster I think
will also be an economic disaster and so
on and so forth so there are signs that
Greece may not be such a weak member of
the EU in the relatively near future and
I would say that that is the
situation that Greece now has to count
from the white hawk if I will see price
I mean I know it's like if I were a
horse but if I would see for us that
would be what I would also be saying to
the country as a way of trying to stay
in power because obviously if never the
more criteria wins the next election
which seems to be what most people
expect then a lot of his policies are
going to be reversed that wouldn't
necessarily be an economic disaster
either because they think a lot of what
is happening economically has less to do
with the internal politics of Greece and
more to do with the balance of power
among the EU countries and that balance
of power is shifting whether you accept
that the myth of exceptionalism which
maybe the powers could exploit and at
the time of the revolution doesn't seem
to have played a decisive role in the
current colonization through debt of
Greece OAC okay well no I mean it
doesn't in fact have that same role and
I think that's a sign that the Greeks
have successfully shed that
exceptionalism to a surprising degree a
lot of scholars haven't noticed that yet
it's interesting you know we've been so
I mean I remember the early years of the
MGS a we were all those of us who are a
bit more willing to stick our necks out
we're fighting this idea that you know
there was only one way to interpret
Greek culture and that was through the
prism of the ancient past and so on and
it wasn't so much the scholars but a lot
of the non academic people who used to
come in droves to these these meetings
and who had been brought up in Greek
schools many of them Greek Americans had
been brought up in schools where they
were taught precisely this version of
the past and and knew very little and
you know it had very little oh I look
very few other sources of information
that's where you started you saw a lot
more of the exceptionalism surviving but
I think that's also part of the tension
between Greeks and Greek Americans today
the Greek the Greek Americans are a bit
disappointing to find the Greeks have
become less nationalistic
yes okay I'll try to answer that it's a
difficult question if I've understood
you correctly I mean in one sense one
part of that is fairly straightforward
which is that nationalism in Europe most
of the European nation states with the
exception of a really small number that
numerically far more of them came into
being in the 19th century there was a
period of time and in fact Germany
itself didn't become a state from there
until very long after Greece had become
the state so the German to come come
back to your question of just for a
moment the German scholars were actually
part of something else they were really
doing the dirty work of the British and
the French as much as anything else but
I think now to respond to your question
the colonial powers working in Africa
and Asia and Oceania decided that the
only way to control people was to have a
very effective form of census taking
well they thought it was a effective so
they would count up the numbers of
people belong to different groups and
then they were draw geographical lines
which became the borders then of very
often subsections of the various states
and of course then the nation-states
themselves were given very firmly
defined borders they were not States
then they were simply colonial dominions
but they had very clearly defined
borders as well if you look at the map
many of the countries of Africa have
very straight lines because that was
simply the way that the colonial
authorities quite arbitrarily divided
these places up their decisions were
even more arbitrary than that so for
example there's one famous story about
some British colonial census takers who
went up River in what is today Nigeria
and kept asking people are you evil and
evil in the local language happened to
mean human being so they said yes
the ebo tribe as a result became very
large and it actually tried to secede
under the name of Biafra for a few years
some of you may remember that then this
same logic was applied to Europe but the
Europeans were not going to be pushed
around quite so easily it certainly the
central Europeans those who already had
a had various kinds of principalities
and small kingdoms and so on the state
the borders were not as straight or as
neat but conceptually they were
understood in that same chromatic way
now there are kinds of polity the
Ottoman Empire of course represents one
the typical Southeast Asian and what the
Thais called Hmong is another that don't
have clear borders that move the weather
where the the edges move according to
the balance of power among the various
leaders and the colonial powers with
their Cartesian logic just decided ok we
have to stop this nonsense we have to
create boundaries
and one of the conditions they made for
countries that they were willing to
acknowledge as independence again Siam
as it was then called and Greece was to
say okay you can become an independent
country one of the conditions we make is
that you have very clearly defined
borders and you police them and so
cartography was big business in the 19th
century as in fact was census taking but
cartography especially there's a very
famous book about Thailand called Siam
mapped by the Thai historian and Tom
chai Winnie Chacoan and he shows how
these cartographers were borrowed from
Western countries but actually they were
doing the work of the Western colonial
powers helping the Siamese helping him
in quotes helping the Siamese to draw
very clearly defined lines so that then
the abutting territories which were
controlled by the British and French
would not have to worry about any
ambiguity where they're where their
influence legs they then proceeded as
they did with Greece to demand more and
more tariff preferences it sounds
familiar these days doesn't it but but
the the the fundamental thing that made
that possible I think was the drawing up
of those borders so there was
consolidation there was a kind of
logical coordination and many of these
countries that emerged in the 19th
century found themselves with borders
that cut straight across linguistic
lines and included within them mixed
groups of people who spoke multiple
languages anyway the next thing that had
to be done and I think this is the real
answer your question is to tell the
governments of these countries
now that you have borders now that you
have recognition as a government you
have one more fundamentally important
task to do and that is to create a
national culture and people then began
to develop what one anthropologist years
ago a Spanish anthropologist and
historian
Calabar oh ho called the myth of
national character that's no such thing
as national character we take any two
Greeks you can there will argue about
what it means to be Greek
now then turn round until the foreign of
course we know what being Greek means
but but they will argue with each other
and the whole point about this model of
national character is that nation-states
are predicated on a model of the
individual person has a property owning
entity and so the state then is a
property owning entity for two reasons
it owns a territory but it also has a
culture anthropologically the concept of
a culture is untenable there's no such
thing as a culture there's culture which
is a process that culture changes if you
ask me what I am
I'm the child of German Jewish refugees
I grew up in England my dream probably
at least three languages I have a second
home in wrong I live in the United
States what does that make me in the end
usually when people ask me what are you
I simply say I'm an anthropologist I
don't have to have national borders to
be an anthropologist it's much more
convenient that's my point that that the
concept of the nation-state is one of
the most successful pieces of deception
ever perpetrated by humans on other
humans because there is no such thing as
a absolutely homogeneous national entity
and even if there were for a moment it
would very quickly start to shade in
different ways if that shading becomes
too aggressive then there are
accusations of of separatism and you
know people have sometimes accused me
and fermenting separatism in zone II
anomaly because I I rather enjoy
speaking their dynamic but the point is
that you don't you know these are these
people are going to be the first to
volunteer there's over another war with
Turkey for example so yes you can
implant a sense of loyalty to the
National ideal people become very taken
up with that and they believe it and
it's certainly not for me to question
their sincerity I think it's absolutely
clear but the way in which this is
engineered look
on the surface like the grant of
Independence my argument is precisely as
I think you will understood that it's an
independence that serves the interests
of Greater powers who are trying to
control they I think you put it very
nicely because they attempt to try to
control that larger territory by saying
ok we'll give you boundaries you police
them does that answer your question
so don't go away and we can ask the
speaker more questions but I'm going to
go full circle since Michael's first
book was a critique of folklore I'm
gonna let our resident folklorist have
the last question thank you so much
Michael for this rich talk I have two
questions I like very much the idea as
you mentioned that there is no one
culture the same as there is no one past
and you mentioned that the neurologists
in Greece challenged this idea of the
past do you think that if Greek scholars
consider several pasts of Greece could
have a better concept of the Greek
identity so antiquity post antiquity
Byzantine past Ottoman past and current
situation so if we consider all those
pasts and I have a second question can I
ask how yes but may I answer your first
question while I still remember it and
then we'll go back to a second one but a
long day so I would not divide up the
past in that period izing way that you
just did you know in other words I don't
think that we could talk about the Greek
the classical past and the Byzantine
vast as separate entities there's a risk
there of drawing boundaries across time
in the same way that the colonizers drew
boundaries across space and so
conceptually I don't think it works very
well but I think you're right in another
sense which is that if we think the
different pasts as different types of
interpretation of the past and if Greeks
learn as I think they are learning and
we all have to learn this to accept the
idea that the richness of a country's
cultural heritage lies precisely in the
cacophony of different interpretations
that I think leads to some much more
interesting possibilities I don't think
that for example any to Byzantine ists
necessarily agree on what Byzantium
represented and probably represented
different things for them not only
me because their intellectual
trajectories are different but also
because their experiences for example of
the church and so on were different
so the past's the plurality of parts I
think shouldn't lie in a plurality of
periods there is continuity between the
ancient and modern world there's no
question about that I know farmer I just
to make that very clear but for example
that continuity is not necessarily about
Athens I did my master's thesis on a set
of folk song texts the so-called
Sheridan easement that demonstrate a
very close relationship with ancient
texts from the island of Rhodes in
Rhodes itself that that of course is
something that the nationalist folklores
didn't want to hear about because that
might have suggested the Grove should
become an independent state okay they
were in in the 19th century there was a
total confusion between culture and
state a nation-state is a piece of
territory with people on it culture is a
process and and this idea that we can
talk about cultures which I'm sorry to
say anthropologists were responsible for
propagating in the in the 19th century
now I think doesn't make any sense at
all and we see it because with the
increased permeation of the world by
people of very different backgrounds and
the fact that they are able to
communicate with each other we can see
that culture is in fact a very dynamic
process so I would say yes lots of pasts
because there are lots of
interpretations of what happened in the
past so your second question and your
notion of crypto colonialism is your
ambition to argue that this is worldwide
notion it it is applicable to all
countries so you started with Greece and
now you're comparing with Thailand do
you there and even even if it is not
even if countries are not colonized by
the Westerners do you think that your
notion would be applicable to worldwide
so my view of classification is what
mathematicians call a politic view in
other words I don't think that we should
try to make lists
different kinds of colonialism they have
real colonialism crypto colonialism
neocolonialism post colonialism it it's
not helpful
I simply throw the word crypto
colonialism into the mix because nobody
has talked very much about comparing
those countries that deny ever having
been colonized and have paid a heavy
price for that denial as well as for
what's done to them and it seems to me
that if after 20 30 50 years scholars
decide that okay this term was useful
but it's now outlived its usefulness if
it had some usefulness I would be very
happy I'm not wedded to the idea of
creating a new taxonomy I think that's
actually a mistake that scholars often
make and in fact you know the folk Lords
of the 19th centuries when all their
time developing absolutely untenable and
very complex forms of classification I
think it is useful to talk about crypto
colonialism just to tell people look the
evil that colonialism did and there were
some good things about it too but let's
talk about the evil crept far beyond
those red patches on the globe that
represent the countries that are
officially we'll call colonies the
British the French the Dutch the
Belgians and others besides and I don't
notice I don't say the Turks I'm not
even going to say the Ottoman Empire
because the Ottomans were had a very
different kind of quality and I think we
need a completely different
understanding of that dynamic first of
all the Ottoman Empire had a huge number
especially in the early years of Greek
bureaucrats Greek speaking bureaucrats
and military men the the the Admiral who
besieged Rhodes in 1480 was called
palaiologos Pasha I mean it's it's a
presumably a member of the Byzantine
royal family and the Greek speaker at
that so that's a whole different
ballgame but with regard to the Kotton
the category of crypto colonialism if
you just listen to the list that I again
that I suggested so Greece Thailand
Nepal Iran Iraq Afghanistan
I won I didn't mention he's very curious
is Iceland now I'm gonna finish by
telling you a story about Iceland that I
think will really make what I'm saying
much clearer one day I get an email from
an Icelandic colleague young
anthropologist inviting me to a
conference in Reykjavik where I'd never
been in my life and he said we wanted to
devote one day of the two-day conference
to the question is Iceland a crypto
colony well I propose was very flattered
and I also had discovered that there
were several scholars mostly very young
ones writing about the idea of Iceland
of the crypto colony I had always
thought that Iceland was a colony
straightforwardly of Denmark so I go to
this conference I remain skeptical for
about three-quarters of the day until
late in the afternoon one very
progressive Icelandic historian stands
up in protest against something someone
had said and in ringing terms in English
said but Iceland never was a colony and
the entire audience burst out laughing
because of course that's exactly what
you know Greeks say and most important a
fakir kinda knows and Thais have exactly
the same expression when can you tie in
any home that's exactly what they say to
say meaning and there he was saying the
same thing and I'd been saying that the
diagnostic feature of crypto colonialism
is that phrase the actual appearance of
the and the actual problems that it
creates for people living in those
countries are very similar to the
problems you find in post colonies so in
the end once we recognize the phenomenon
that it reached much further than it was
supposed to maybe we can just get rid of
the term and that's fine too I think we
have to be much more flexible than
scholars sometimes are in the way that
we adapt our theories to these very
complex and constantly shifting kinds of
boundary making processes of which
colonialism has certainly been one of
the most important thank you
[Applause]
[Music]